t-minus 10 9 main engine start
but five seconds Watney hang on
for that movie that's Matt dad Damon has
this name dead and changed played a
botanist rocketing off the surface of
Mars in the 2015 movie the Martian back
here on earth six would be Mars
astronauts returning yesterday from
their own simulated mission to the Red
Planet the crews spent the last eight
months on the remote slight slopes
rather of an active volcano on the Big
Island of Hawaii Don Dahler shows us
what their experience means for sending
humans to Mars Don good morning good
morning this was the fifth time this
NASA backed research project sent people
to live inside a dome the goal is to see
how they deal with the stress and
isolation and figure out how to select
the right mix of people for a lengthy
Mars mission
[Applause]
the crew of four men and two women ended
their mission with Cheers
hugs and a buffet of fresh fruit a
welcome change from the freeze-dried and
canned food they mainly ate for the last
eight months for me one of the things I
miss from home Portuguese cooking the
project is known as the Hawaii space
exploration analog and simulation or
high seas for short University of Hawaii
professor Kim Binsted the principal
investigator says conflicts during
lengthy space missions are inevitable
she hopes the research will provide NASA
with insights on how to assemble crews
that can remain cohesive despite those
clashes having some variety is a good
thing in a sense we're trying to put
together a toolbox for Mars and if you
have a toolbox you don't fill it up with
hammers solar system sensors tracked to
cruise locations and the volume of their
voices during arguments and if they felt
stressed virtual reality devices allowed
them to escape to a tropical beach
unlike the biosphere two experiments of
the 1990s where some participants were
not on speaking terms by the end
Binstead said this group seemed to get
along crew members were able to
communicate with loved ones during the
study but it was subject to a 20-minute
delay each way that's about how long it
takes for a signal to get from Earth to
Mars anytime they ventured outside the
dome the crew put on mock spacesuits the
harsh volcanic landscape about 80 200
feet up mowin Aloha is similar to what
astronauts will encounter on the Martian
surface we need to send humans out
because it's important for the future of
the species I think it's actually really
important to get off Earth if you look
back at the geological record it is just
full of mass extinctions the next
hi-seas mission is scheduled to begin in
January the members of that crew which
is still being finalized will also spend
eight months inside the dome NASA wants
to send humans to an asteroid by 2025
and to Mars sometime in the 2030s you
can't believe that it's amazing it is
it's a credit
the hawaii partners once you get that
can you come back yeah yeah well I think
that I think that's part of the deal I
think you have to be able to come back
thanks Don sure